la confirmación fue hecha esta mañana
por el instituto de estudios de la
guerra un centro de pensamiento con sede
en Washington que sigue día a día lo que
sucede en Ucrania y también hace un
seguimiento especialmente a lo que se
dice desde Rusia especialmente esos
llamados mini bloggers que son
periodistas o activistas en el terreno
que van actualizando lo que sucede en
sus canales de Telegram pues ellos ya
llevaban días diciendo y alertando sobre
la presencia de tropas ucranianas al
lado este del río deniper frente a la
ciudad de gersón que había sido retomada
su control había sido retomado por las
fuerzas ucraneales a finales de
noviembre después de que de una gran
campaña que hizo retroceder a las
fuerzas rusas que se posicionaron Al
otro lado del río Desde allí atacaban
constantemente con artillería a la
ciudad de gersón lo que había hecho casi
invivible la situación para los
habitantes de la ciudad que o sea habían
quedado o que regresar Pues esta
presencia de las tropas ucranianas aquí
no solamente calma la situación en la
región sino que también ha permitido que
estas tropas hagan reconocimientos hacia
otros sectores y alerte a la población
ucraniana de que esto podría ser uno de
los primeros pasos para esa llamada
contraofensiva de la que ha venido
hablando el gobierno de kiev que busca
retomar el control de esas regiones del
Sur del país y del este que están
todavía bajo control ruso